everybody trying to get rally on these
garyvaynerchuk.com videos so wanna bang
one out real quick little bling crow
thought figured you know I'm gonna try
to make these thoughts too big and that
leaves me not communicating with you
guys as much as I'd like to so I'm gonna
go with micro thoughts a little bit more
often so here it is you know not
allowing your employees to speak on
Twitter or Facebook or any other social
network and fear that they may something
say something wrong out there and that
would affect your business is insanity
and I guess the picture that I want to
paint is it's like forcing all your
employees to ride a horse to work and
what I mean by that is the ship has
sailed the day of employees not being
able to talk is over and what you need
to do is not treat it like a communistic
thing where we're not gonna let you do
things you need to treat it as a
capitalistic thing let them talk react
if somebody tweets I hate my company or
our products up you fire them and you
miss you a heartfelt not bullcrap public
apology consumers understand the deal
there are a lot smarter than all you top
executives out there they're trying to
analyze what's good and bad there is a
humanization of business coming and
people recognize that we're all flawed
we all have flaws and no employee can
[ __ ] your business I promise and so
by allowing them to be out there and
humanize your brand or your business you
will be attracting new business you know
there's clearly an indication of that
when you see what's going on with the
best buys in Zappos I highly highly
recommend that you really rethink this
process of approving everything an
employee says we're having the PR
company heavily involved we need to open
up the reins allow people to talk share
feelings that brings a lot more emotion
to the table and most of all you're just
fighting an uphill battle you're on the
wrong side of history the ship has
sailed
allow it and react to it instead of
closing it down and creating a very
awkward and